barricade stopped these protesters from
getting close to the parliament building
in colombo where their elected
representatives were meeting
inside the chamber the government faced
a crisis
41 parliamentarians left its coalition
taking away its majority in the 225
member house
the prime minister's son who resigned
with the entire cabinet on monday
questioned the calls for the president's
resignation
where is the plan where is the rope map
who is the leader who will be appointed
say go to bayer chobaksa resigns who
would be appointed after that
it has to be from this parliament
constitutionally no one can be brought
from outside
what happens to that person if he is not
part of this people's struggle will he
be sent off as well
but angry sri lankans are in no mood to
listen to what they see
as more excuses
every day more people join protests like
these by healthcare workers who along
with medical specialists are warning of
a shortage of life-saving drugs we have
in fact decided to list the items that
are at the moment short supply so we are
trying to discuss this with the
authorities and then we might even go
for a
international open appeal if the
authorities are unable to supply these
things
through the health health services
the castle street hospital is a place
for women that deals with any emergency
at any time but when we don't have the
required supplies we can provide a good
service and that's the situation now
as the demands for the government to
step down increase president gotabe
rajapaksa has called on all political
parties to join efforts to solve the
crisis
many have turned him down saying it's
too late mine fernandez al jazeera
colombo